[موسيقى]
اخبار السودان بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم اشتباكات المسلحه بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع اندلعت وسط
وجنوب العاصمه السودانيه وبالقرب من القصر
الرئاسي وقياده الجيش ومقر اقامه عبد
الفتاح البرهان رئيس مجلس السياده في
الخرطوم كمن دلعت اشتباكات مماثله في
مدينه مروي وعده ولايات اخرى في البلاد
ونقابه الاطباء تناشد كل المنظمات
الانسانيه العامله في البلاد التدخل
العاجله لاسعاف الجرحى قائد قوات الدعم
السريع حمادي يقول للجزيره ان العمليات
القتاليه ستنتهي في القريب العاجل وان
افراد وحداته مع خيار الشعب السوداني وان
الجيش يجب ان يعود الى ثكناته من جانبه
يقول البرهان ان الجيش ما زال يحكم صوت
العقل ويطالب باعاده قوات الدعم السريع
التي دخلت الخرطومه الى اماكنها ويؤكد
للجزيره ان الجيش لديه احتياطات جيده
وقواعد عسكريه لم يقوموا بتحريكها
الامم المتحده تعرب عن قلقها بشان
التطورات في الخرطوم وتقول ان مزيدا من
العنف لن يؤدي الا لتفاقم الامور وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه يقول ان الوضع في
العاصمه السودانيه هشه في حين تدعو
الخارجيه التركيه الاطراف السودانيه
للالتزام بانجازات العمليه الانتقاليه
والحوار منصات التواصل العربيه تتفاعل مع
الاحداث والاشتباكات في السودان عبر عده
هاشتاقات ابرزها الخرطوم وقوات الدعم
السريع وسط تمنيات المغربين باستقرار
الاوضاع واستتباب الامن في البلاد
الى اللقاء